Peter King back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Peter hey thanks rich
so nice of you to say happy it is a must
read every single darn week Peter what
would you say is the story of week 17
now that we're a few days removed from
it what's that story the bills making it
and the bills totally freaking out and
being so happy and and you know rich I'm
just gonna read you I'm just gonna do
one thing that in my opinion that sums
up what really is special about the
Buffalo Bills okay Richie incognito he's
played everywhere he's seen everything
and Richie incognito on the bus on the
way from the stadium in Miami to the
airport to go back to Buffalo said to me
this win is for the City of Buffalo this
is for the people from all walks of life
the average joe's who show up at all our
games rain Sun wind snow sleep
everything and all they do is root their
asses off for us this city is the butt
of jokes everybody makes fun of us but
these people they just keep coming and
supporting us
week after week the city is amazing I'm
telling you this wins for them that is
the coolest thing it's just because we
get so we get so spoiled by you know the
money and everything else but but I'm
just telling you this is one of the
reasons why I hate the fact that the
Oakland Raiders aren't gonna exist
anymore the Oakland Raiders should exist
in Oakland til the end of time the
Buffalo Bill should exist in western New
York till the end of time there are some
places that do not deserve to have their
hearts ripped out and their guts ripped
out despite whatever the economics say
and that's why I was so happy for the
Buffalo Bills on Sunday and also their
fans deciding impromptu I don't know who
decided I'd love to know who was the
first person to say let's donate to Andy
Dalton's foundation you know it
fantastic you know I'm watching hey I'm
watching the CBS Evening News last night
Jeff Glor and they're halfway through
the show and there's Andy Dalton and his
wife on a remote sitting in front of
their Christmas tree just miles the gape
saying my god yeah these people gave us
170 thousand dollars he was unbelievable
it's great it really is great and and we
were discussing it earlier on to Peter
did that pass save Marvin Lewis's job
too you know what I don't know
I mean rich it's Mike Brown just can't
quit Marvin Lewis it's just I don't know
if I were a Bengals fan I'd be totally
exhilarated by the end of that game and
quite honestly I'd beat the press you
know and again I love Marvin Lewis
we all do but I mean it's just time it's
time to try something new it just is
it's not working it hasn't worked and
they have a competitive team it's a good
team there's nothing wrong with the
Bengals
it's just that Mike Brown is is an
insult insulated guy and you know it's
it's I mean look I lived in Cincinnati
the first five years of my marriage in
the first five years of my professional
life I covered the Bengals Paul Brown
was as good as any human being could
ever be to a young writer trying to
learn football I stood with him in
Wilmington Ohio two-a-day practices in
1984 and he taught me football was an
absolutely incredible experience and I
really really have great affection for
the Brown family but it's time to move
on from Marvin Lewis I don't know why
they don't see them Peter King of the
mmq be the mmq be calm joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so yes or no
right now as we're sitting here Gruden
call that game on Saturday on ESPN in
the booth do you think he's there oh I
think so isn't he gonna be there well I
mean he says he is but to me I think he
says he is
ESPN says he is because the the Raiders
have to satisfy the Rooney rule right I
mean yeah that's the only reason why
he's calling his staff around our you
know my colleague and yours Ian Rapoport
said either he's he's he's gonna have
the greatest flag football coaching
staff or he's gonna coach the Raiders
based on what I know I mean there's a
reason why Paul Gunther I think isn't
very aggressively you know gonna take
one of these jobs right hey I'll just
say this if you see paul gunter take
another job you know then defensive
coordinator the Oakland Raiders be
careful because maybe this thing blows
up like I rich I wrote about this today
and I was told that that Mark Davis
since his father's death has tried three
previous times to hire Jon Gruden and
failed every time and that isn't to say
in no way that it's gonna fail this time
because I think it's absolutely gonna
work but I'll believe it with finality
when the print when I see him at the
press conference but I I you know it
strikes me that he's doing this game
this week and they'll announce it Monday
or Tuesday but I I don't know anything
well solid about that I assume he'll do
it without seeing the practice of the
juice right but the only thing I would
say the only thing I would say about
that is that Andy Reid is probably his a
number one mentor in football and so he
and Andy Reid it's bigger than this
football game for them but again I don't
I don't have any idea what the rules of
the rules have engaged when they're
gonna be this week Peter King joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show for a couple
of more minutes
have we seen all this shoes drop yeah of
coaching in the NFL right now Peter I'd
be curious to see what happens in
Tennessee uh Monday or Tuesday not that
I'm expecting
malarkey to go I just I'm waiting to see
what happens in Tennessee I'm waiting to
see what happens in
houston it appears as though bill
O'Brien's going to stay if for some
reason Bill O'Brien doesn't stay that
could set off a very interesting chain
reaction Bill O'Brien is eminently
well-liked
and any year where there isn't a
slam-dunk assistant around the league I
think Bill O'Brien would upset the
applecart in a lot of ways and might
even cause some teams that thought they
were retaining their guy to make a
different decision but that's just that
that I don't expect to happen
I expect O'Brien to stay in Houston
especially now that that it looks like
Rick Smith is going to be off for an
extended period of time
with the terrible news that his wife is
battling breast cancer so I've got 90
seconds left which is an absurd amount
of time to try and capitalize the Hall
of Fame vote I've got the heart out at
the end of my first hour you're Peter
who do you think makes it what do you
think makes it in the Hall of Fame I
mean what gray Lewis is gonna make it I
think I think Randy Moss is gonna make
it I think I think Tony Boselli is gonna
make it huh but but again I mean every
year and I mean every year I'm surprised
you know I've heard a lot of buzz in the
last few weeks about Ty Law you know he
might make it I don't think that there
is an absolute slam dunk guy beyond Ray
Lewis and everybody else is up for
debate
Peter really appreciate the time we'll
chat hopefully one more time before the
Super Bowl and then at the at the big
game to always love our chats great
rates we love being on with you thanks
Peter
that's @si underscore Peter King the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience